the I grew up in a teacher's home my mom
was a teacher and still is and she
really celebrated the written word and
characters and she would scour the news
or newspapers for any new movie that was
coming out and this was the late 60s so
movies were a little more of an elixir
and not quite thrown at you in the same
way that they are now and she was
convinced that it was okay to take me at
age eight or nine to go see carnal
knowledge because she felt well I can
always cover his eyes during the sexy
parts what's important is that you see
these wonderful characters and their
written by Mike Nichols who we've
listened to those comedy records of
nickels in May and this the same guy and
my mom would be so ferocious about
bringing you know stories and
performances and just searing tales of
life you know into our home that I think
the ticket takers around San Diego knew
us from from a block away it would be
you know Mother's tall figure my mom
dragging this little kid but it was to
see like medium cool or the graduate and
they would always give me this look when
I just remember being a little kid
walking into some of the theaters around
San Diego and they would give me a look
they give her a look and then they kind
of shrug and let us in to see the movie
and that was kind of the citadel of of
what entertainment is and what it was to
to lose yourself in a world of people
that you hadn't met before and so the
first movies that really kind of brought
that magic
into our lives you know Hal Ashby films
Mike Nichols films the Graduate catch 22
movies that invariably had music in them
and even from a young age I knew that if
you could marry music with those
characters and with that great
photography you had it all and that
started practically from the first movie
I ever saw